hey here's a really weird story you
might remember a Fox News host megyn
kelly who is no longer a Fox News host
she actually left Fox to much fanfare I
would call it too much attention and she
got to NBC shows there was going to be
this Sunday night weekend's special
we're like on the first or second
episode she interviewed Alex Jones and
it was sort of a letdown that it was
going to be this big blockbuster show
when she was able to get unhinged
conspiracy theorist Alex Jones is one of
her primary interviews and then she has
this daytime show and the daytime show
has been total cringe I mean an absolute
disaster we've done a few stories about
just the terrible ratings and how it was
really a pretty bad move for NBC and
that she's just not really the right fit
for that sort of daytime softer more
milquetoast type show so cut to
yesterday where she did a really odd
segment about the hard-hitting topic of
Halloween which is upcoming and she
still managed to say something
ridiculous this is Meghan Santa is white
Kelly and she was reminiscing yesterday
about the good old days when she was a
kid when it was fine for white people to
wear blackface blackface of course is
the makeup used by a non black performer
playing a black role and it has a long
history of discriminatory intent and the
sort of context of it is pretty
disgusting when you understand it really
hard-hitting segment and she still
manages to get attention for her show
for something completely negative
take a look you still be able to dress
like a [ __ ] you do get in trouble if
you are a white person who puts on
blackface Halloween or a black person
who puts on white face for Halloween
like back when I was a kid that was okay
as long as you were dressing numbers
like that's character if somebody feels
like something is offensive to them then
you should say it and that's fair game
take it if you're gonna dress up well
yeah you gotta be able to take the
all-white panel on her show was weighing
in and trying to figure it all out even
george w bush's daughter later in the
same segment was saying you know people
should be able to reasonably wear
costumes that they want to wear but you
should have some adherence to common
sense and decency at some point so I
started looking into megan kelly a
little bit she grew up in Albany New
York it's sort of difficult to imagine
that in the late 70s early 80s when she
would have been like 9 to 12 or even 14
that blackface was just seen as a lovely
thing to do in Alberni New York right I
don't know I mean there are some racist
parts of the north you'd say but it
doesn't strike me as a particularly
racist area it's Albany New York it
seems like a culturally revisionist part
of the story here and she later ended up
apologizing like within hours of this
going out Variety reported that she sent
an internal email to her colleagues
apologizing which said quote I realize
now that such behavior is indeed wrong
and I am sorry the history of blackface
in our culture is abhorrent the wounds
too deep I've never been a PC kind of
person but I understand that we do need
to be more sensitive in this day and age
particularly on race and ethnicity
issues which far from being healed have
been exacerbated in our politics over
the past year the ugly history of
blackface is what's missing from the
analysis it's not about the PC police
which see seems to correctly identify
it's not also about pretending that
blackface is the greatest injustice it's
simply not this is about appearing
clueless and making a dumb unforced
error imagine being NBC you pay her
untold millions of dollars nobody
watches this dumb daytime show there's
nothing even being discussed about it
because nothing interesting happens
there's finally something that happens
that gets people's attention except it's
the host you're paying millions of
dollars to and you lured her away from a
job that was probably a better fit for
her on Fox News defending the use of
blackface in Halloween costumes right
even if megyn kelly didn't have any ill
will behind this comment you'd think
that she would have the PR savvy to know
that you don't say that type of thing
that's exactly right and blackface is
something that was used historically to
portray that this sort of minstrel show
sort of idea
and I would say it is actually different
if a white person is portraying a
specific black person there are
situations where makeup can be used to
create a more accurate portrayal that
would not be reminiscent of this context
in which blackface existed but is this
even really a battle we need to fight
right like if the n-word and blackface
are part of this horrible history of
repression and slavery and
discrimination can't we just say you
know what we don't really need blackface
I just think that megyn kelly should no
longer comment on holidays and holiday
candles and the Santa is white thing and
yeah the Halloween blackface thing was
she gotta say about Thanksgiving I don't
know was she part of waging against the
war on Christmas at FoxNews I don't
remember Reilly covered its so
extensively I don't think even Neda she
didn't even really need to yeah that's
right today's program brought to you in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman blinka
is a great service that i use all the
time what they do is they take thousands
of the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink as'
I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS Jobs and there is a great new book of
BS Jobs by David Graeber which I
listened to on bling cos they're
constantly adding new books to the
platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I'm putting a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you like it you can continue enjoying
thousands of condensed audiobooks for
about five bucks a month that's be li NK
is t.com /pa k mas